you know I did some quick math in my
head and I'm almost positive that at
least 65% of the dialogue in this movie
is trouble with the curve is a new movie
starring Clint Eastwood Amy Adams and
Justin Timberlake now he didn't direct
this movie a lot of people are confused
about that this is actually the first
film that Clint Eastwood start in since
in the line of fire in like 1993 that he
did not direct that's one of the biggest
reasons I was looking forward to this
movie because basically it's been 20
years since he's been in a movie that he
hasn't directed himself it's about an
aging baseball scout who is having some
problems with his eyesight he has a
daughter Amy Adams who he doesn't really
know very well and she's forced to come
with him on one last trip he takes out
to scout for new players basically the
point that Eastwood is in in his life
now any character he plays will be aging
in some way or shape or form as usual he
does a very good job in this movie and I
loved Clint Eastwood he's been one of my
favorite actors filmmakers forever I
mean think about it really he directed
his first movie in 1971 I mean and he's
still making films nowadays and he's
been like a Class A actor forever I mean
the guy he's a living legend he may play
different variations of the same
character over and over again but you
watch the movie because you like Clint
Eastwood you just like what he brings to
a movie and there's something to be said
about a guy way older than most of the
common movie stars of today who is still
bringing an audience in who's still able
to be that entertaining and can still be
a convincing physical presence who can
beat the crap out of young kids as he's
what an Amy Adams are forced to go on
this trip together to look for potential
Major League Baseball players his eyes
start to fail and she has to step in and
kind of be the person who's looking for
all the signs that he's supposed to be
looking for you could just see them bond
again I can tell East was definitely
attracted to stories a father-daughter
bonding like Million Dollar Baby for
instance along the way they run into
Justin Timberlake who is also now a
baseball scout and Amy Adams and him
kind of strike up a strange little
relationship how is this movie it's not
bad it could have been a lot better I
think I was disappointed in this movie
largely because I was expecting more
from Eastwood's first acting role he's
taken in almost 20 years that he didn't
direct that being said - the movie is
not that bad and I think that for people
who weren't expecting something he'll
probably enjoy it more than I did
you had higher expectations see I've
always loved baseball movies when I grew
up the Sandlot Field of Dreams the
natural these are movies that I watched
over and over again and I've always
enjoyed playing baseball and baseball
has always been the sport that's closest
to my heart even though I liked playing
basketball more for some reason baseball
was the one that always made me feel
more like I don't know like an American
I guess that's what I called the great
American pastime so there is that
quality this movie has that all baseball
movies that are good seem to have were
it just it feels really heartfelt and as
usual Eastwood is great in this movie
despite the fact that most all of his
lines end with C my main problem with
this film is that there are three major
stories Eastwood and his daughter that
was compelling his daughter and Justin
Timberlake getting to know each other
that was fine and there was another
story of Amy Adams job she was a lawyer
and there's all this pressure from that
there's a possibility that she might get
a promotion and she doesn't want to lose
that but she has to go with her father
and that's causing stress on her job
that subplot was there to create more of
a tension with her and her father and
you know give her more of a backstory
but every scene involving her job as a
lawyer was boring they could have found
a way to sidetrack that I know they
could have because that entire subplot
every time went back to that I was just
like oh it felt very procedural like
just let's just get through this let's
give her a job and a backstory but then
they kept going back to it and going
back to it and just felt so cliched and
at certain aspects of Clint Eastwood's
job as a scout Matthew Lillard played
like this villainous you know boss who
was against him because he was aging and
it just felt really cliche but the thing
that this movie has is a lot of charm
and that's because Eastwood just brings
this intense likability to all of his
roles and that's what won me over in the
end I think if you rented this movie you
would be perfectly satisfied but if you
were like me where you had higher
expectations going in then you might be
disappointed but if you thought it was
gonna suck like right off the bat then
he might be pleasantly surprised I'm
gonna give trouble with the curve of
b-minus it's not when I he splits better
movies but it's certainly not one of his
worst thanks a lot for watching guys and
as always if you liked this review then
you can click right here
and get stuck man I've Punk